läuft die Kamera deutschland droht der
Linksrutsch wir sind heute im
Rot-Rot-Grün Berlin wo jetzt schon
Verhältnisse herrschen wie in Nordkorea
wir sind undercover unterwegs das wird
nicht ungefährlich
los geht's
als erstem Kamerateam gelingen uns
Bilder von den Herrschaftshäusern der
rot-rot-grünen Kaste ob die einfachen
Menschen des Wagen werden in dieser
Diktatur ihren Mund zu öffnen
Berlin wird ja Rot-Rot-Grün regiert was
stört Sie an der Regierung trauen sie
sich das zu sagen
also nicht stört ja eigentlich nichts
doch ich trau mich ja dann machen sie
nein
ist die Angst groß hier gerade in der
Bevölkerung offen die Meinung zu sagen
ja
[Musik]
alles klar dann wollen wir sie nicht
weiter vielen Dank danke schön eine
Atmosphäre der Angst was uns auffällt
Prachtbauten auf der einen Seite und
gnadenloser Zerfall auf der anderen
[Musik]
ja das ist eins der beliebtesten
Restaurants im Rot-Rot-Grün Berlin die
imbissoase Öffnungszeiten 11-
heute ist wohl Ruhetag an einem geheimen
Ort sind wir mit einem Vertreter des
Oppositionellen Widerstands verabredet
Mario R von der CDU bietet dem
diktatorischen System die Stirn Berlin
ist ja im Prinzip eine
runtergewirtschaftete kommunistische
Diktatur bald regiert von einer
abschreiberin was ihr im kriminellen
berlin-milieu ja scheinbar auch hilft ne
absolut ja also anscheinend sind viele
Berliner so naiv dass sie solche Dinge
gar nicht interessieren und solche
Politiker sind aus meiner Sicht jetzt
nicht unbedingt Vorbilder überraschend
offene Worte seit unserem Interview ist
Mario R spurlos verschwunden wir hoffen
auf Antworten im Zentralkomitee nur hier
dürfen wir wirklich offen drehen
ich will nur zeigen dass ich Linien treu
bin
will da keine Schwierigkeiten kriegen
ich versuche sensibel zu fragen
ja erstmal herzlichen Glückwunsch zu den
soliden Umfragewerten seitdem sie
regieren
als sie sind ja schon immer sehr
auffällig solide
ich will nichts andeuten
die Stimmung kippt fast wäre unser dreh
hier zu Ende gewesen die Parteikollegin
ist vielleicht eher bereit über Berlins
Probleme zu sprechen sie sagen es läuft
eigentlich ganz gut ich zähle mal auf
höchster Kriminalitätsrate zweithöchster
Arbeitslosenquote stärker Personalmangel
bei Bürgern Gesundheitsämtern
schlechteste Luft aller deutschen Städte
und der mietendeckel war ja auch eine
Pleite und Pleite passt hier wiederum
auch ganz gut zu Berlin der mietendeckel
war keine Pleite das war erstmal sehr
mutig dass das versucht wurde ja und
jetzt sagen wir wollen den mietendeckel
auf der Bundesebene durchsetzen was dann
blüht zeigen diese eindrucksvollen
Bilder von Berliner luxuslofts zwischen
Geld und Abriss haben Jugendliche hier
überhaupt eine Wahl wen wählt ihr ah ist
noch nicht ganz sicher also ich schon
sicher ja also ich tendiere zu grünen
ja also
ich war mir nicht ganz sicher ich bin
ein bisschen zwischen grün und der FDP
ehrlich gesagt bitte was den Grünen und
der FDP aber Peter darfst du nicht sagen
okay okay gut ja also alle drei grünen
Lebensmittel sind die hierher jetzt habe
auch ich Angst um meine Sicherheit ich
muss hier sofort weg aber lässt man mich
überhaupt dann können wir jetzt einfach
gehen ne ich kann jetzt einfach gehen
bitte schönen Abend noch
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]